قبل كانون الثاني (يناير) 2017 ،
لم يكن من
الممكن تحويل مرآب منفصل إلى منزل ،
ما تغيرت القوانين في
كاليفورنيا وأيضًا في عدد من
المناطق
الأخرى هو السماح لك بإعادة توظيف
أرض ذات قيمة لا تصدق
نحن في حي رائع  كل
البنية التحتية هنا
تم تشييدها بالكامل في الحي
، ومع ذلك تم استخدام هذه القطعة المعينة من
المساحة لتخزين النفايات غير المرغوب فيها ، لذلك في
مقاطعة لوس أنجلوس
يوجد 290 ألف مرآب منفصل مكون من
سيارتين يمكننا تحويله
إلى منزل مثل هذا
نقوم ببنائه  هذا ونحن لا نفرض رسومًا على
صاحب المنزل مقابل ذلك ، فلا يوجد امتياز
على العقار الذي ندفعه مقابل
ذلك ، ونشارك دخل الإيجار مع
مالك المنزل ويتراوح تدفق الإيجار
اعتمادًا على الحي
بين أربعة آلاف وعشرة آلاف
دولار في السنة و  في نهاية
عقد الإيجار لدينا عادةً ما نغادر لمدة 15 عامًا
وكل هذا
لا يزال ملكًا لمالك المنزل
دون أي تكلفة
[موسيقى]
نبني شيئًا واحدًا ونفعله بكميات كبيرة
إنه حقيقي  التصنيع وليس
البناء الذي يتيح لنا خفض تكاليفنا
للوحدات ،
لذا بعد تحقيق هذين الأمرين ،
يمكننا توفير الإسكان بسعر منخفض
للغاية ونتيجة لذلك نقوم بالإيجار بسعر منخفض للغاية
ونبحث عن المستأجرين الذين يعملون في هذا
المجتمع  ولا يمكنني تحمل تكاليف العيش هنا ،
فهم يتنقلون لمسافات طويلة بخلاف ذلك ،
ما أحبه في البرنامج هو
حقيقة
أنني لم أفعل أي شيء ولكن
تم التوقيع على الخط المنقط من جانب واحد
وخرجوا وفعلوا كل شيء  حصل العمل على جميع التصاريح ،
كان كل شيء نوعًا من مشروع كامل ،
وأنا أعلم مدى صعوبة العثور
على مكان لائق للعيش فيه ، كما تعلمون في
منطقة لوس أنجلوس
، وشعرت أنك تعلم أنه يمكنني القيام
بدوري
في المساعدة في الحصول على سكن ميسور التكلفة  من
خلال جعلهم
يبنون الشقة في الخلف والتي
تعلم أيضًا أنها ترفع قيمة عقاري أيضًا
[موسيقى]
عندما بدأت في القيام بذلك لأول مرة ،
اعتقدت حقًا أن مالكي المنازل سيكونون
مدفوعين بالكامل تقريبًا بالاقتصاد الذي يعد
من أكثر الأمور إرضاءً
لقد تعلمنا عند القيام بذلك أن
حوالي ثلث أو أكثر من مالكي المنازل
يفعلون ذلك لأسباب الإيثار ،
حيث
يرون الممتلكات التي يدركون
التحدي في مجتمعهم من أجل
الإسكان الميسور التكلفة وهذه طريقة
دون أن يضطروا إلى جلب المال  أنه
يمكنهم في الواقع
توفير شيء ما يوفر السكن
لأفراد المجتمع الذين يخدمون المجتمع
ويحتاجون إلى منزل